we are taking calls at 6 1 7 830 4750 we
will take our next caller from the 281
area code caller what's your name and
where you calling from my name is Dade I
am from Houston Texas cool what's on
your mind um I'm a new youtuber and you
being a youtuber yourself I was
wondering did you start off from 0 subs
or did you have a website before the
help you gain subs or what did you do
for that yeah so I mean the YouTube
channel started in September of 2009
with zero subscriptions all we had at
that point was a podcast that was a
little bit listen to but not hugely so
we basically started from scratch and
you just got to grind it out I mean
obviously it's great if you get a couple
of viral videos that will get you a ton
of subscribers but it's it's it's a
grind and it's been you know now I think
we're close to 300,000 subscribers and
there's been no magic you know when we
have more videos doing well you get more
subscribers more quickly and then there
can be some lulz it's a lot of ups and
downs but there's there was really no
trick to it for me so you'd say it's
just a grind I i'm purty continent i
would say if you've got to put out the
content regularly and if the content is
good enough to make people say oh I want
to see the next video this person does
then hopefully they click the subscribe
button that's what sort of the gist of
it all right um one other thing I
consider myself to be left-leaning and
during the beginning of the 2016
election I was a Bernie Sanders
supporter but um after Bernie Sanders
lost the democratic the Democratic race
and Hillary Clinton was the nominee I
found myself to be more of a trump
supporter just because I couldn't find
my self supporting Hillary Clinton at
all do you think that was really common
this election no i don't i think it's
completely nuts well i don't know how
you
could go from supporting Bernie Sanders
to then voting for Trump because Hillary
Clinton wasn't someone you liked I mean
was there any particular issue on which
you agreed with Trump over Hillary
Clinton um to be fair I didn't vote for
Trump I couldn't make myself vote for
Trump either but I really couldn't like
I found myself to be more of supporter
of Trump and there aren't really what
but hold on our analyses I'm confused
you said you were finding yourself to be
a supporter of Trump but you didn't vote
for him who did you vote for I didn't
vote for anyone I mind you I can vote I
am 18 I just didn't I wasn't enough of a
trump supporter to go out of my way to
vote for him so basically you chose not
to participate and to let the election
pass you by having no influence on it at
all with your vote you just said I'm
going to sit on the sidelines because
bernie is out basically yeah now that I
control is more dovin that's more of a
concern your first question was were
there Bernie supporters who voted Trump
I think there were very very few Bernie
supporters who voted Trump but what
you're actually saying the fact that you
supported Trump is sort of irrelevant
because you didn't vote for him you
basically were a Bernie supporter who
didn't vote at all and yes I think there
were too many of those people and it's
at I think you said you vote in Texas
wouldn't have made a difference there
but in other states it could have made a
difference and it's a real problem I
think that that's a real real problem
and Democrats had had voter turnout been
higher than we wouldn't have president
elect Trump right now see the problem
with that is i could have never made
myself vote for Hillary because I
thought she was just too much of
untrustworthy I couldn't trust what she
said yeah do you trust Trump um I trust
Ron to do what he thinks he thinks is
right and what do you think he's going
to do unfortunately I don't know right
now um so you trusted finally these are
things he thinks is are right but you
don't know what any of those things are
doesn't sound too trustworthy does it
I'm kind of on the fence I'm really
trying to see what Trump is going to do
it's more of a hate for Hillary Clinton
than a like for some yeah all right well
listen unfortunately I think what we're
hearing here was all too common during
the 2016 election and it is very very
sad and partially responsible for the
circumstances we find ourselves in
thanks so much for the call good luck
with the YouTube channel appreciate it